Speaking of automation, it's worth
mentioning the autofocus attribute.
Autofocus automatically puts the cursor
on an input when the input is rendered,
making it easy for
users to quickly begin using the form.
Thus, the browsers immediately
move the focus to the input field.
However, mobile browsers ignore
the autofocus attribute, so
that the keyboard
doesn't randomly appear.
The Google home page, for
example, as you could see here,
uses the autofocus attribute on the
search bar, because the vast majority of
users just want to start typing
the queries as soon as the page loads.
See, use autofocus when you
want to save your user's time.
But be careful because it will still
keyboard focus and potentially
prevent the backspace character
from being used for navigation.
Also, it's recommended that
you only autofocus inputs
that are above the fold.
Otherwise, the page will scroll
down immediately upon rendering,
which can be jarring.